[Music]
good morning
i am
uh leonard senior fellow at the american
enterprise institute i
i get to speak first so uh um welcome
everyone good morning i'm delighted to
be here uh on the panel uh with my much
history colleague
dr frederick
um
kagan
one more chore
we would appreciate your questions of
course
and i believe that there should be a
banner
on how to submit those questions
uh both fred and i will make uh brief
introductions um five to ten minutes and
then um
we'll talk to each other and most
importantly to you
um three years ago i titled the book
that i'm writing now a small victorious
war
uh in russian that's marine corps
and the phrase was uttered by the
minister of interior and the chief of
the secret police the gendarmes which
islam
who was a key supporter of the
disastrous war um with japan uh
1903-1905
the full quote reads to thwart a
revolution russia means a small
victorious war
the book records the evolution of the
putin regime
toward a military state and his own rule
towards what one of the chapters uh
title calls wartime presidency the
watershed occurred um in the run-up to
putin's third presidency in 2012 and it
is described in the second chapter of
the book which is titled choosing war
i'll be happy to explain later on but
this is relevant
because um at that time putin began to
replace economic progress
and um higher standards of living as the
source of his popularity um and his
by extension the legitimacy of his
regime um with the defense of uh russia
against alleged uh uh uh enemies in the
west and the recovery of the
superpowership glory uh lost in the
soviet demise um from the distribute
distributor of wealth
uh he became the defender of the
motherland and the avenger of what he
firmly believes was the defeat of the
soviet union at the hands of the fools
and traders inside and committed western
plotters on the outside and the
consequences of this choice of this
decision are upon us today
tracing the evolution um
made me believe that within a year or
two of the 2014 election where putin
essentially is going to be crowned
president for life
um he would undertake his own small
victorious war
um against the member country um uh on
nato's eastern flank
in this scenario he was it was going to
be a quick in and out crimea style
um with the annexation
of a sliver of land
of one of the baltic republics with a
significant ethnic russian presence and
then confronting nato with um the
decision of going to war against russia
something that putin believed and i
think now believes even stronger another
would never do
so humiliating and essentially
hauling out the west defense defensive
alliance uh would be in putin's mind the
ultimate revenge for the demise of his
real farm fatherland which is not russia
it's the soviet union
i think that there is still a strong
possibility of such an operation
but for now putin has chosen a different
um small victorious war but if the
strikes and here i defer totally to what
fred is going to tell us but my amateur
sense that if the um air strikes are
followed by an occupation the war is
likely
not to be either small
or uh in the end victorious most
importantly it would signal nothing
short
of the change of the domestic political
regime let me explain again um
afraid will will
tell me uh where i'm wrong but given
russia's dominance in the air and in the
tanks
heavy artillery and missile systems
which put in so assiduously and at a
great cost to his state um has been
modernizing in the past decade the
initial victory over a regular ukrainian
army will be swift and devastating yet
occupying and policing on europe's
largest second largest after russia a
country over 44 million is certain to
become an increasingly nasty and bloody
chore when they fought for their
country's independence following the
bolshevik revolution and then again
during world war ii ukrainians proved
fearless and fearsome bertisan gorillas
um
urban warfare particularly in major
metropolitan kiev kharkiv odessa
will begin to take its toll on the
russian troops almost from the very
beginning
and at home the mounting casualties will
be met first with growing resentment
younger brothers and sisters wives and
fiances and in many cases our parents of
those killed in the soviet
and russia's longest war in afghanistan
are very much around
and they do remember the sealed zinc
coffins and burials in nameless graves
they will be the catalyst
of what almost certainly would become a
national discontent as more russian
soldiers are killed
russians love putin when the wars are
quick and are and incur minimal losses
if putin chooses to go beyond their
strikes this campaign will be neither
and putin knows it this assumption led
me to believe that the wide range
invasion was not likely
yet the domestic hedge here domestic
political hedge will work only if putin
cares about public opinion as much as he
has in the past to be sure of late he's
taken some um serious domestic political
risks as when he alienated millions with
his pension reform and the so-called
constitutional referendum but overall as
regards public opinion putin has been
minding it rather
studiously
in signaling putin's disregard for
public approval
a massive invasion of ukraine would
indicate nothing less than the change of
his regime
the change from what daniel triesman and
sergey garyvee called informational
autocracy to what they termed old style
all-style
dictatorship
the informational dictatorship i relies
muslim propaganda
symbol manipulation it seeks public
approval uh by persuasion again
propaganda the rhetoric of performance
rather than by instilling
fear
excuse me
um
it silences the elite opposition by
coptation
bribery and censorship rather than jail
repression is present
but deployed selectively by and large
that has been putin's motors apparently
so far and if he chooses to wade into an
afghanistan like quagmire he cannot but
change the regime to a traditional
authoritarianism a police state where
public opinion no longer matters this is
likely to be the most significant and
troubling consequence of what we're
seeing in ukraine today and again
i did not believe he was ready for this
change um and that was another reason
for me to think that uh he would not
attempt a full war uh invasion
yet if he does this will be
a classic pyrrhic victory when jazz was
allowed in the soviet union for several
years during the world war ii alliance
with the us the refrain in a song by a
popular crooner leonid joseph went
kitumpa davila sakula the shark choked
on the whale
ukraine is almost certain to become that
whale for putin and this war beginning
of the end of his regime
russian history is both unambiguous and
unforgiving where military defeats are
concerned virtually all of them
precipitated regime change
defeat in the crimean war 1853 to 1856
resulted in alexander the second
revolution from above the plea for of
liberalizing reforms beginning with the
manu mission of sirs
the loss to japan
produced the first russian revolution
and forced nicholas ii to exceed to
constitutional monarchy the setbacks in
world war one led to the february
revolution and
nine months later to the bolshevik coup
and the widely hated war in afghanistan
um became a key factor in gorbachev's
launching glaston's
and perestroika his revolution from
above which led to the demise of the
soviet union
a history above putin knows this story
well which also made me think that he
would not or he would be reluctant to
take that risk
thank you
thank you leon um
unsurprisingly i agree with every single
thing that you said um i would worry
about myself if i find myself
disagreeing with you materially
um
i i was also wrong in uh in my
forecasting and the forecasting that i
did um along with isw's russia team
under the leadership of its terrific
uh team lead uh analyst mason clark
um
uh we have been assessing for months
that putin was unlikely to launch the
full-scale uh ground invasion and
occupation of ukraine
um
for various reasons um some of them uh
as as you laid out leon some of them
having to do with military technical
issues about the way that russian uh
ground forces in particular were arrayed
around ukraine
um
i think
and so um honestly as we're tracking
this crisis i'm also formulating in my
mind and with the team our own after
action review to uh to determine exactly
why we were wrong
um which which we will likely publish at
some point um although it's mainly of
interest to us i think
um and i i think at the moment i'm
inclined to say the primary factor that
we got wrong
is that putin went crazy
uh that putin changed his he really has
changed in some fundamental way
russian has so many wonderful ways of
putting things and crazy in russian is
sumachi
which is literally uh walked away from
his mind
um
and for some weeks it's been it's dawned
on me that actually he putin i think
really has walked away from his mind
in in a fundamental way and that um
that sort of craziness has manifested
itself
in a number of ways um
one of which is that he had so many
other ways he was setting up skillfully
so many other ways of achieving the
objective
of regaining control of ukraine
without having to launch
a dangerous and costly military
operation he was doing so well along so
many of those non-military lines of
advance
that this is unnecessary from the
standpoint of actually regaining control
of ukraine
i assess and continue to assess that
this was unnecessary
he was likely to be able to create a
circumstance in ukraine within a couple
of years at a minimum in which the
country was ungovernable
um and the current political order was
cracking there were ukrainian elections
for parliament scheduled for 2023 and
then president 2024
um and it looked like and i think this
is true that putin's guys
were setting uh
informational and domestic conditions in
ukraine and in europe and with us
uh
to create a much more advantageous
environment for him
uh to play around with in that time
period
and that looked like first of all the
kind of classic play that putin has been
doing for 20 years
uh and very much in accord with his
preferred courses of action much less
risky than what he's doing right now and
certainly much less costly and for all
of those reasons uh we assessed and
forecast that he would not do what he is
currently doing
uh and yet here he is
he has in fact launched the ground
invasion
um uh we've had uh russian troops
advancing uh along uh at least five axes
uh north from crimea uh they've pushed
north and they're driving toward
the nipro river i'm choosing to use even
though my background is in russia and
i'm choosing to use ukrainian names for
ukrainian places
so they're driving north toward the
nippero river they have attacked
mariupol
not only with missiles but also by
ground
they're attacking around uh kharkiv
uh the second largest city in ukraine
very close to the russian border and
they're driving uh south from belarus
and from russia
on kiev itself
um these operations so far
are
they're not it is not being conducted in
the way that a
competent professional military would
conduct an operation
the ground operations began uh within
four hours of the start of the air
campaign
uh they began before the russians had
secured air supremacy so
there have been ukrainian combat
aircraft flying around shooting at
russians
this is insanity
on the russians part and it's
unnecessary
the russians had the air and missile
capability to destroy the ukrainian air
force's ability to operate even if they
didn't destroy destroy all of the
individual airframes
and they chose not to they chose to
move ground forces forward in an
environment in which there are ukrainian
combat aircraft still operable this is
this is an unnecessary risk and it's not
something that a normal competent
professional military would undertake
initial attempts to take mariupol by
ground were repulsed
this is also crazy
given the force concentrations that the
russians have down there and the ways
that they could have approached that
there was no need for them to suffer
initial
uh setbacks
um there are reports that they have been
repulsed along other axes of advance
this is all temporary i want to make it
very clear that the russians will win
the conventional war here
uh the the sheer
uh weight of forces
that putin has assembled around ukraine
is enough to grind the ukrainians down
um and and eventually destroy the
conventional ukrainian military
and seize and occupy whatever positions
in ukraine putin chooses to do that
russia's ability to do that is not uh in
question
but
i
had a lot more respect for uh gerasimov
the russian chief of the general staff
and i had a lot more respect
for jeroboam the commander of the
western military district and
frederickoff the commander of the
southern military district these guys
fought in syria
uh they're competent professional
military officers they've written
brilliantly about their experiences
uh these guys know better than this
and so
i think this one of the second errors
that i made
in uh my forecasting was not taking
enough account of rumors and hints that
we were getting that putin was getting
quote bad advice
and i really i i look forward to
learning at some point in history who
was actually giving him this advice
was it shogu is it the was it the
minister of defense who is not a
professional military man
is he playing the the hermann goring to
ada to putin's hitler here
and and providing the the the word that
his boss wanted to hear
yeah
we don't need to stall it yeah
right there yeah there's a there's a
track record of this kind of thing
at least bulging was a professional
military man
but yeah yeah but you know shogu was a
politician i mean he's been in this
position for a long time i i have no
evidence of this
um only only little bits and pieces but
someone i think has been giving putin
bad advice
and so we have so far a surprisingly
inept
uh opening campaign honestly it
reminds me more of the initial soviet
operations against finland
um than anything else now ukraine is not
finland
uh and this is in stalin's soviet union
so putin will lean into this and i want
to be very clear that we should expect
that the russians will
win this conventional war
uh and the ukrainians will not be able
to stop them but i think that the
prospects are much greater than i had
feared
that the ukrainians will be able to
blood the russians significantly in the
process
and
i think that's incredibly important for
the reasons that leon laid out
uh i don't think that this is not
looking like this is going to turn into
and we'll see you should take everything
i say with a grain of salt because i've
just told you that my various forecasts
have been wrong
um for some time
but this looks unlikely to turn into a
suddenly a shockingly effective
blitzkrieg uh where the russians will
sort of shake it off get their heads
together and then this will this will go
smoothly i think this will be ugly
um i that is to say i think the
conventional phase of this will be ugly
and the ukrainians will be able to score
a lot more hits than they should be able
to given the correlation of forces
and resources but the ukrainians will
eventually be ground down
i agree with leon that there will be a
significant ukrainian insurgency
uh putin has stupidly done
everything he could to ensure that that
will be the case
uh the rhetoric that he has been using
if you ask yourself you know reflect on
this
in 1941 adolf hitler invaded the soviet
union
at close to the height of the stalinist
purges
after stalin devastated decimated
actually technically more than decimated
i think he killed more than one in 10 oh
yeah of his officers
his military
and done horrific things to his people
stalin nobody loved stalin in the soviet
union uh except for his lackeys and they
feared him more than they loved him yet
when the germans invaded
the russians fought like lions
why they were not fighting for stalin
they were fighting against an adversary
who had made it clear that his objective
was to exterminate them like vermin
putin has made a similar mistake
in
telling the ukrainians what lies in
store for them
at the end of this war
he's not saying that he's going to
exterminate them
but he's made it very clear that he
intends to conquer them
subjugate them by force
and compel them to become
uh
serps
in a renewed russian soviet empire
and he's made that clear in no uncertain
terms he's done nothing whatsoever to
offer any positive vision
to any but his lackeys and poop and boot
lickers
in ukraine
and he's done more than that
he has assembled uh the forces of a guy
named ramazan khabirif
a chechen war criminal
who specializes in atrocity
uh on ukraine's northern frontier he's
concentrated khadirov's guys in belarus
um
listen
there's only one thing that kadir's guys
know how to do
they know how to commit war crimes and
atrocities that is their professional
expertise
and when you concentrate those guys uh
on a border and you make it clear that
you intend to send them in
that's not going to persuade ukrainians
to surrender that's going to persuade
them to fight to the death
so i think that we're very likely to
have uh a move toward irregular warfare
and insurgency here
and um this is not going to be a short
victorious war
as leon said with the consequences that
i think leon has described
now i think it's important to step back
from the details of this
and just make another observation that
transcends the issue of russia's future
which is which is nato's future
so
we have a problem here
one problem is we we can discuss the
moral ethical position that we've
adopted of riding ukraine off
and deciding that uh the united states
and the west is going to watch
uh putin uh just invade and subjugate
an innocent peaceful state that posed no
threat to him that is our formal
position
uh and we can we can discuss the moral
ethical wisdom of that
we can also discuss this geostrategic
wisdom of that but it's beside the point
because that's the decision that has
been made and i'm confident that it's
not going to be reversed
but we have to look beyond ukraine
because ukraine is not the end as leon
said the objective putin's objective is
not
just to win ukraine
it is to reconstitute an empire
which empire
well that matters
certainly the soviet empire
if the georgians are not currently
quaking in their boots they should be
because the georgians were also
mentioned by nato in the uh bucharest
statement
as being promised nato membership
whenever this major phase ends i fully
expect putin to look at tibelisi and say
so
are we done with this now or where are
you
uh and i do think that at this point
georgia will would be an easy fight for
putin even whatever difficulties his
military encounters in ukraine
and then the baltics listen
americans
you need to internalize something
the world has changed
a key pillar
of the post-cold war world
has just collapsed
the entire post-cold war order
was based on the reality that there was
no significant russian conventional
military threat to nato
every single aspect
of the post-cold war order in europe
rested on that fact
nato defense budgets rested on that fact
nato military posture rested on that
fact
american defense budgets
have rested on that fact american
military posture has rested on that fact
what does it mean
if putin took a force of the size that
he now has or even one considerably
smaller
and targeted it at the baltic states
with the forces that we currently have
there
we could not defend them
now worse than that
we could not defend poland
with the forces we currently have in
theater another of putin's favorites
and the former member
unwillingly
of that saddest empire
we could not defend poland with the
forces that we currently have in europe
we could defend it with the might of the
american military
but we would have to flow divisions into
europe
to do that we will have to do that
so as we continue to imagine that we're
going to stop investing in readiness now
and we're going to focus on
modernization and we have to stop
worrying about europe and the middle
east and we have to focus like a laser
beam on taiwan and china no
we can't
we have to be prepared to defend nato
militarily against a russian
conventional threat for the first time
since 1990
and that is a change in the world and
we're going to have to wrap our heads
around it some way
um i think i'll stop there i'm i'm and
we've got lots of questions in the queue
leon so i think uh maybe we should start
addressing yeah you you start you start
um clicking them i think there's the
first question essentially
and i'm going to direct it to you uh
fred essentially
we have we have people on the left and
on the right making excuses for putin
and essentially saying uh it doesn't
matter to the us uh uh what happens
there so so i think the questioner wants
us to um weigh in on to why why that
matters
look ukraine matters to to the united
states for a number of reasons
one of them is
i've you know i've said this so many
times but it bears repeating
there has been no greater beneficiary of
the rules-based international order
than the united states of america and
the american people
we are the ones who have benefited from
that most
we are the ones who have the most to
lose
from the destruction of the rules-based
international order
what putin is establishing is the is the
hobbsian principle of international
relations
okay the strong will devour the weak
and as the russians sometimes say
candidly when speaking privately only
great powers have sovereignty
okay that that is a world of war that is
a world on fire
and it will not be confined to ukraine
first of all putin has made it clear as
i just said that he has targets beyond
ukraine and some of them include nato
countries
so the united states will rapidly be
faced with the choice of adhering to
the alliance which is the gold standard
by which all other american defensive
commitments are judged and we need to
understand something about nato because
we've taken it for granted for 30 years
there is a legal
category
in the united states of major non-nato
ally
and i just want to mention what does
that mean what is the implication of
that
the implication of that is that
the american commitment to nato is the
standard by which all other american
commitments will be measured
it is the highest level of commitment
the united states can give to any
country
that commitment has not been in question
for 30 years for much longer than that
in fact
if it comes into question
all of our commitments
will be shaken our commitment to japan
will be shaken our commitment to south
korea will be shaken our commit all of
our commitments will be shaken
xi jinping will pay attention to that
he is paying attention to this khamenei
will pay attention to that he is paying
attention to this and we can say all of
these things
don't matter but you know that's just a
fictional world in which they don't
matter
because the global economy matters to
the united states and the destruction of
it will matter to americans president
biden has been making this case
partially one could make it more loudly
so there are legal moral ethical
geostrategic and practical economic
reasons
why this matters a great deal to
americans and we we need to find a way
to internalize that
um fred i i think you see the questions
right yeah i think you pretty much
answered the question about taiwan why
it matters to taiwan
um if you want to say more but but what
else the u.s should be doing now
and um
what's what what's available to to buy
the administration to be sure with all
those things that you mentioned because
it may be too little too late
well you know i mean it's given that
that we are not going to fight russia to
defend ukraine
we we can't save ukraine we should
continue as i believe the administration
is doing
uh to rush aid to ukraine
and to turn this into putin's
afghanistan war
um and to provide the ukrainians as best
we can with the resources to make this a
very bloody and painful fight
and defend their own country as they as
they are
putin is threatening hellfire against
anybody who helps them and we need to
stand up to that threat and help them
anyway
um
but beyond that listen we need to be
mobilizing american uh i hate to say
this but this is reality we need to be
mobilizing right now american mechanized
divisions and flowing them to nato's
eastern flank not to invade russia not
to defend ukraine not to attack but to
make it very clear to putin that this
stops here
that this this is it we're no
we're not going to play games anymore
we're recognizing what an inflection
this is this needs to be the the
the iran revolution moment for joe biden
this because you know one of the
remarkable things that people often
forget about jimmy carter
is that after the iranian revolution
broke out
after the soviet invasion of afghanistan
jimmy carter realized that his strategy
had been wrong
and he began
what what became the reagan military
buildup
and he began a change in american
military policy and posture that needs
to happen now we need to recognize that
uh coercive economic diplomacy has
failed
and that sometimes you need to bring a
gun to a gunfight and again i'm not
saying that we should be fight you know
sending armor divisions to fight in
ukraine i am saying that we need to send
them right now
to poland and make it clear that we will
stand against putin uh if he tries
anything else
uh fred that reminds me of reagan's
favorite uh it's not uh it's it's not
easy but it's simple
yeah
a couple of couple of notes i can't i
mean you you're you're always so
provoking me to uh to to at least try
and say something interesting um
not to compare putin to to those two
monsters but what you're describing of
putin um going off his head
it reminded me first of all of stalin
during the fir 41 until zhukov saved
moscow and that at which point
essentially apparently there were some
words essentially zhukov told him not to
mess around um
and
god knows where he got the courage to
say that but i think i think stalin at
that time was
expecting uh
to be
running to uh to uh uh volga to save his
life so he allowed church to do it
it also allowed me remember me of hitler
4243
with the with the
constant orders
not to retrieve from stalingrad even at
the obvious at the obvious um uh danger
and trend of being encircled which is
exactly what's was of course joker's
plan and exactly happened
in december december 42 january 43.
so
so
they do have i mean you're in power for
22 years fred
show me somebody who is not a little bit
sumachi um after after that much in
power who advises him uh as part of my
research
his kgb bodies
he does again again
as hitler and stalin he does not trust
professional military
so uh if you i mean
unless you want to say something but i
think you already covered russia china
and and axis powers being emboldened um
and you see that question directly
addressed to you i believe
uh which about uh when when will he win
the convention sure that russia will
yeah
yeah okay
i i can't i can't give you an estimate
because
we're gonna have to see what the what
the russians actually do here it in
principle
they seem to have begun this operation
before all of their forces were fully in
place especially for the drive on keeve
um so
and i want to be very careful here
because i want to tell you i mean i want
to remind those of you who don't
remember in 2003 when the united states
began
uh the attack
and we did a brief and very intense uh
air campaign
and then we rolled forward
there were pauses in our operation
and uh in the midst of those pauses this
also happened in 1991
in the midst of those pauses we we had
reporters saying oh look it's already a
quagmire it's vietnam um
you know the it's this the americans
have already screwed up and and they're
not going to complete the invasion which
turned out to be ridiculously wrong in
both cases
um so i want to be i want to be careful
not to make that mistake here
um i'm assuming because we will we don't
have visibility on this that the
russians are in fact now concentrating
uh the various forces that were not yet
ready and hurrying to move them
uh forward
and if they do that then it can be a
matter of a few days or a week uh before
the russians are able to drive enough
power through
uh the ukrainian defenses to overwhelm
them
um so it really could be anything from
from a couple of days to a week
but if the russian ground forces
continue to sort of mess around the way
that they have been
with little bits and pieces here or
there it could take a lot longer
there's also a question about whether
putin is trying to do this slowly
because he doesn't want to get drawn
into big combats and he doesn't want to
get drawn into urban warfare and he's
hoping
to break the ukrainian's will and get
them to collapse or something
uh and possibly patricia or um
the fsb director who just keeps
still
there well colin would have dealt with
that with a nine millimeter uh solution
i i'm
i'm a little surprised that nothing is
still alive but
um you know those guys may be telling
putin that they've got some brilliant
scheme to take zelinski down and do so i
don't know
um so it's very hard to say this this
could be the conventional phase could be
over in a couple of days uh it could be
going on a couple of weeks from now um
but it really depends on how rapidly the
russians concentrate their power
and how effectively they can actually
wield it
uh and it's just too early to tell at
this point
um let me let me just weigh in on
something that fred said
as part of my research for the last two
chapters of the book um i i looked at
every study of of uh possible russian
action in the baltics
i just want our our our viewers and
listeners to understand that that there
are rotating battalions in in in all
those three countries there are about a
thousand uh troops from various
countries um
and uh without air power without heavy
uh equipment and so on and so forth um
facing them uh
is a 340 000 uh strong um uh western
military system
um the only thing and there you know
there are all kinds of studies of how
quickly the russians can do it um but
but the only thing that can possibly
deter putin and i totally agree here
with fred
is to deploy enough actually ren said
eight brigades uh with air support tanks
artillery
to tell putin that he cannot do it quick
and easy
um and he might be repulsed on the
conventional first phase um because
after that you know there are all kinds
of things that show that it will take
three to four months um to uh for nato
to fully mobilize and bring its forces
by then again here's the um playbook
from crimea uh that part of of uh
whether it's uh
estonia latvia uh will have a so-called
referendum uh asking to join uh russia
it becomes part of russia and and then
you have to go to war with russia uh
which again i i think nato is probably
not going to do um so
there is there is urgency here um my
sense is that
uh again
if this small victorious war i thought
it would be closer to the 2024 election
to provide kind of you know spectacular
uh outburst of patriotic um uh feelings
and it's wrong on two scores it's too
early and it's not likely to provide uh
that sort of thing because because the
russian troops are not fighting the nato
i'm sorry not fighting nato they are the
russians have pretty much given up on
the baltics
and and uh
there is there is
there is a sense um that uh
it will have to be will have to be done
uh very quickly um
when will we if we ever see those eight
brigades or hopefully more uh deployed
in in the baltics i mean i'll
i'll i'll leave it to fred but i think
it's very unlikely
i don't know
all right so uh we have the question of
again fred everybody's and i don't blame
them they're all interested in the
nitty-gritty uh the infrastructure right
um yeah yeah well has it why isn't
russia targeted critical infrastructure
like electrical power i can't tell you
um this is something that is in a in the
standard playbook
um i expected them to do this i i think
we have clearly seen
look it's very clear that
i think
i want to be careful saying very clear
it looks to me as if the putin
is trying to do this
in as limited a way as he can to cause
as few casualties as he can
to do strikes in a way that demonstrate
the ukrainians will lose to break their
will
but without uh really sort of
devastating the country
because of course you know his objective
i mean we do need to remember that now
so
i'm i'm scared to say this because so
far a lot of my assumptions about
putin's
feelings reality
well yeah but the feeling that he needs
to stick within any of the narratives
that he's created
uh have been wrong but i i think it's
important to to reflect on the
narratives here which also will answer
another question about what is his
objective
um look like hitler and i'm very
comfortable making that analogy by the
way even though putin is not engaging in
genocide
uh here and i don't think intends to
um but like hitler putin is telling us
exactly what it is that he's going for
there we shouldn't be confused about
this um and his speeches this week have
been um insane but have also you know
made the clear the objective and
it's hard to read especially the speech
last night or the brief speech last
night and the one immediately before
that as anything other than declarations
of intent to annex ukraine into russia
in some way
i'm not actually persuaded that he is
even thinking that he can set up some
sort of puppet government
and have that be a final
solution uh for him it may be an interim
step but the
the complete destruction in his in his
rhetoric of any support for any kind of
sovereign ukrainian state
it leaves him relatively little room for
a solution other than breaking ukraine
into provinces and bringing them
separately into the russian empire
um
well
you know again i'm saying that he's
walked off his mind but
it's it's still it's still within limits
i think there's still a bounded
rationality here
and when one is trying to conquer a
country to absorb it
it's desirable to destroy as little of
it as possible
and if he has the notion
and this is i think one of the potential
miscalculations if he has had the notion
whispered to him by patricia for others
that you know most ukrainians really are
under to understand that they're
russians most ukrainians really are with
him
and they're not going to fight for this
corrupt oligarchic government and all of
that sort of stuff if he actually
believes that
remember the speech yesterday began with
a call to ukrainian service members to
put down their arms
okay i mean i get that you can do that
but it's great it's that crazy way to
begin an announcement of a war when it
we know that they're not going to do
that and they have certainly haven't
done that
so i think it's possible that he's
trying to sneak up on this in a way
and create conditions that he hopes will
cause ukrainians to surrender without
doing too much damage
um
and like that the only other thing i can
say about why he hasn't taken down the
critical infrastructure like electrical
power or communications is
we had assumed that he would of course
if you think that you're going to
operate
heavily in an information domain and if
you think that you're going to try to
influence the attitudes of the
population that you're attacking
you have to have some means of doing
that
and if you shut off everybody's
communications then you can't talk to
them either
so i i want to hold open the possibility
that he actually feels the need to
maintain a line of communication to the
ukrainian people
because he needs to communicate with
them
or wants to be able to i'm grasping at
straws here because none of this is sort
of doctrinal military approaches to
these problems or anything that we would
have expected the russians to do
uh let me start um on on one question
here and then and then i'll um
kick it to you uh fred uh offensive
missile so one things that putin
mentioned in his
diatribe speech uh the long diatribe
speech
was that a ukrainians have a tochika
missile which i think is a very old
russian
missile tactical missile and that and
that they have some residual military
i'm sorry uh nuclear uh components which
i think they surrendered under the uh
under the uh bucharest uh 1994
um uh uh treaty so fred i mean they lied
about
you know for example shoujo uh uh i mean
it's a typical glives operation of
hitler's uh shogu uh in the in the um
that infamous and i i want everybody to
see that sitting of the of the national
security council uh very interesting um
it's on youtube and uh
and sri guru said oh yes there was a
terrorist group that was trying to to
infiltrate russia we we killed all of
them we we got one um as a uh
as a prisoner of war so so putin might
as well um like a lied about the
missiles and the nuclear nuclear
wherewithal what do you think oh yeah no
that's nonsense i mean it's a
combination of and it was interesting to
be denoted by the way that i don't know
it was six or eight weeks ago
lavrov the foreign minister uh actually
referred explicitly to the movie wag the
dog
um and he was talking about uh he was
accusing us of doing that but of course
putin is doing that too and it a lot of
this the nuclear discussion that they're
having right now reminds me very much
of the and this has nothing to do with
the b3 bomber uh uh scene in wag the dog
um which has all the reporters going
what's the b3 bomber and then they go
off and start asking and of course there
is no b3 bomber and the point is to
distract everybody
uh the ukraine has no nuclear
capabilities um
what shogu keyed off
zielinski made a rhetorical mistake
and i actually think he misspoke he may
be wrong but
he did refer uh in his own speech a few
days ago
to the budapest memorandum in which
ukraine agreed uh to give up all of its
nuclear weapons uh in exchange for
guarantees from russia among others uh
of its territory um and zielinski made a
comment in his speech a few days ago
that uh it might be necessary to revisit
the budapest memorandum
i don't know what he was actually
talking about i
and i don't want to go too far
speculating but the russians immediately
seized on that as saying that zielinski
was saying that ukraine was going to
require a nuclear weapon and then they
got then they went into just total
crazy-pants land
and shoigu said that the ukrainians
could acquire nuclear weapons faster
than iran or north korea
well
okay north korea has nuclear weapons
so it is not physically possible to
acquire weapons faster than north korea
has them
um so this is this is a nonsense and
this is all a part of the
um
of the effort that the russians have
been engaged in to persuade anybody
that ukraine poses some sort of a threat
to russia
that justifies this invasion but leon
this is the thing that has baffled me as
i've watched this
so they they they set up all of these
false flag provocations they had this
invasion of russia by these bunch of of
idiot ukrainians which i don't think
even happened
um and all of these provocations they've
got legal cases going on as they review
these kinds of things they've got the
accusations that the ukrainians are
going to acquire nuclear weapons they
said all sort they started all sorts of
hairs
that in a couple of years ago
they would have spent time elaborating
these into full-scale information
operations where you have ukrainian
ukrainian service members confessing
one on on you know channel one to the
plot and you have evidence presented of
the ukrainian nuclear weapons and all of
that kind of stuff and then they go to
the united nations and say that ukraine
has done all of this kind of stuff and
they
they started all of these things and
then putin just
shocked them all
waited for none of them to come to
fruition
and just launched in a way that left
them all kind of as hanging chads
the only explanation that i can offer
there is i do want to give the biden
administration credit for one thing here
there actually it deserves credit for a
number of things
um and it's important to give them the
credit that they do deserve
but in one respect there has they have
been fighting an information war against
putin that putin has never seen anyone
fight against him before
and the biden administration has been
aggressively
blowing
all of these false flag operations
identifying when the russians were going
to stage a coup telling zielinski that
telling the world
and i think
at that national security council
meeting when putin rips the face off of
nareshkin the fsb director who's in
charge of running mostly no svr
svr director who's in charge of running
most of these things
um
i have a theory
i think putin was actually very angry at
nadyshkin
because
narishkin has blown it repeatedly
narishkan was i think supposed to make
all kinds of things happen
like a coup like an actual ukrainian
provocation like all of this stuff and
we got inside uh we the u.s got inside
of all of norishkin's games
and blew them all up before they could
come to fruition and i think
that this may be one of the reasons why
putin just said okay
screw it
we're going i don't care i don't care
about these operations
and
i
it had lost patience with nadeshkin and
then humiliated him publicly
it's a it's a thin it's thin gruel to
make much of an argument on
but i think that that's one of the
things that's going on
here so we need to be very careful not
to fall for these various russian
information operations about the
ukrainian nuclear weapons and missiles
and so on
um fred looking at the
the bunch of the
last three questions um
i'll i'll let you of course weigh in uh
just one my sense is that no it's not
going to spill into poland and the
baltic states um
too much on the plate already um and um
i i don't think we're we're going to
attack venezuela cuba uh um to to
stretch the russians he
it's all rhetorical he doesn't care much
about either
i don't think well
listen i'm a little bit more concerned
about the possibility of this expanding
to involve um nato states
one way or another
look the harder a slog the russians make
this in ukraine the less concerned i am
about putin immediately turning to do
anything else
the risk that i saw was that if they
actually did turn this into a splendid
little you know sort of blitzkrieg
operation
that putin might feel emboldened to move
rapidly somewhere else
um but
unless that unless this becomes that i
think he's not going to be inclined to
do that but look
i do think that it is virtually certain
that the polls are going to lead into
backing
the ukrainian insurgency
um
putin is going to be furious about that
by the way as a measure of the
incompetence of putin's information
operations even hungary's orban
condemned the invasion that's a big deal
because putin had so thoroughly suborned
orban
that i would not have bet a kopeck one
way or the other
on how orban would react to this
but putin has done this in such a
ham-fisted way
that even orban found it necessary to do
that orban may also find it necessary
therefore to support
uh resistance
um which in principle he would prefer
not to do
uh so i think we're gonna have nato
states involved i think directly in
supporting
uh insurgency in ukraine as they should
and as we should
uh putin will announce that that is an
act of war he will announce that those
are provocations and he will he will do
various things
we cannot take off the table and i just
want to reiterate this i don't want to
be hyperbolic and i don't want to be
alarmist here but i just want to say
i we need to shake ourselves out of our
complacency
and recognize that the nato line is not
a magical curtain
that automatically defends nato states
and this leon you were making this point
superbly in your book and in the
scenario that you described
we have to understand that the the days
when no one could ever think about
attacking nato country are passing
and i and we need to we what you're
saying is exactly right if putin
conducted an incursion
into poland for example
if russian forces drove northwest
from grodner in berus
to link up with the russian forces in
kaliningrad
and established their own sort of land
bridge between those two that cuts off
the nato ground line of communication to
the baltics
and we are then in a position of having
to counter attack against russian forces
to reopen it you're talking about the
so-called svalky cevalky
yes
right from our perspective it's a
corridor from the russian perspective
it's a gap
but the suvalky corridor which is it
it's sep if you look at a map and i'm
sorry we don't have a map up but if you
look at a map it
there is a thin strip of territory
uh in where poland and lithuania
actually have a direct border and
there's a rail and a road line there in
the nearest town is suvalky in poland
we need that rail and and uh and road
uh carter to get reinforcements into the
baltic states the russian objective will
be to cut it
if they did that now and if we or at
some time soon and if we
had then to contemplate a counter-attack
to take territory away from them
that it's not a crazy scenario to
imagine that putin might do that
and we need to be prepared for that
militarily and we're not prepared for
that now now that by administration is
sending more forces to europe which is
good
but i fear that the scale is too small
of those forces
and i'm afraid that they may not be the
kinds of forces that are required i
think to conduct mechanized
counter-attacks
uh against russian uh positions and this
is very worrisome so i am worried about
this spilling over and i we cannot take
for granted that that isn't
uh going to happen
uh fred just just to add to what you
said uh there's been a actually started
on the medvedev um there's been a steady
stuffing of kaliningrad with hardware um
including and that again happened
underneath video of the is there um dual
dual use um uh tactical missiles um i
was told uh actually when i traveled in
the baltics uh researching this book i
forgot two minutes to to reach uh talon
or something to that effect yeah um so
an enormous danger um from from
kaliningrad now i don't see
any more questions uh i'd be happy to
chat with you but i think we probably
need some guidance uh from our um
our hosts to see if um we continue or or
we just stop here because because there
are no more questions
well there are a couple of other
questions that we that we could address
i think um
the question about um
will the re-emerging german military uh
oh yes that's right that's right uh you
know become indispensable yeah
yes uh i mean it is important to say
i'm
saying that the united states is going
to have to relook its defense budget and
its forced posture we
we are the country that can most rapidly
build up its military
and most rapidly deploy and yes we can
afford to do this
we've been telling ourselves that we
can't but that is a choice
and we need to make a different choice
right now
we can do this much more rapidly than
the european states are going to be able
to build up militarily
but they have to
and
the reason why i focus on what we have
to do and i want to be very clear about
this
we only control ourselves
the united states is not an empire
and we don't dictate
policies to our allies
we ask them to do things we suggest that
they do things we put pressure on them
to do things but we don't control them
so
we have to affect what it is that we can
control
and that's why i focus on what we can do
because i don't like to try to conduct
national security policy in the
subjunctive
talking about what other people should
do
but i will do that here and say the
europeans should get their heads out of
the um sand
and recognize that the universe has
changed and that they are also going to
have to think about bringing guns to a
gunfight and it is time for the germans
to get over the post-world war ii
uh hangover and i think actually bill
gallston had a terrific op-ed about this
a few days ago
uh in which he said you know
he said as it he said this is this is
bill galston saying you know as a jew
born one year after 1945
it shocks me to say that it's very
important for the germans to get over
the lessons of the second world war
um but but he he is absolutely right uh
germany is the largest economy in europe
it has the greatest potential military
power
um
it has since the second world war been
committed to not doing that
and i've been largely in favor of that
because if you look at the recent sweep
of european history uh europe has been
more peaceful when germany has been
relatively disarmed
um but the reality is i'm not worried
about a german uh
you know re-engaging in some kind of
aggressive activity in europe but that's
not something that we need to be worried
about i am worried about defending
against russian aggression now
and germany is going to have to gird its
loins and look itself in the eye and
decide
uh if it is going to play the role that
it should play france and bill gallston
made this it was really as a commended
to everyone it's a terrific op-ed
um
uh france is also going to have to get
past
the goalism
and decide that it's just it's a member
of nato without without an asterisk
um because the the french there has been
an
asterisk in the minds of the french
about french membership in nato and
responsibilities to nato ever since de
gaulle and that needs to end
um and the french need to commit to nato
and they need to commit to being a
military power in nato and invest in it
and of course the british need to need
to step up their military defenses too
this has to happen europe has to rearm
to defend itself
um and and germany does need to lead the
way but it's going to be a hard slog i
see we managed to prompt another couple
of questions
um all right um
again fred um
please weigh in um take turns uh
tactical nuclear weapons to defend paul
and the answer is no although
again as part of my book research one of
the chapters is is called worshiping the
nukes um
putin's been well partly because that's
the only superpower legacy he had he is
now trying to create more but on
worshipping really um saint seraphim of
the seraph is now patron saint of
russian nuclear weapons i have a few
paragraphs on this and putin went to the
monastery uh why is why um why sarah
because that's where the father the real
father of the of the uh russian nuclear
weapons uh lavrenti beria um that's
where he said so-called set up so-called
arzamas 47 the super secret town where
among others sakharov worked um but also
of course korchadov and the number of
others um they of course you know all
the all the nuns and all the monks were
killed um the monasteries and churches
were desecrated and then putin said what
the hell
i'm a born christian
and he and the um holiest father the
patriarch of russia i i unfortunately on
that one i don't have a photo but i
certainly have a write-up
from from one of the russian news
agencies they presided over the opening
of the seraphim's
monastery and then
waved to the parade of monks and nuns
he is talking of of going off his rocker
he literally worships the nukes um in
one of the tactical or operational
consequence of that and again alfred you
i'm sure you know more about this is
this
very determined development of of
tactical nuclear weapons
um uh including including we're talking
about really short range very low yield
and again i'm not i'm not an expert on
this but what i hear from from or read
from the experts is that that's that's a
very suspicious development in other
words
you go in and you explode perhaps in the
area that that's not populated assuming
right uh or sparsely popular you explode
you know at point 2.3
um megaton
uh just to scare off nato and show what
what you're up to what do you think
it's russian stated doctrine to do that
at this point um it's the the russian
russian military writings about this are
quite clear correct correct exactly
exactly in response to a conventional
attack which in their opinion threatens
the very existence of the russian state
well right apparently ukraine uh exactly
exactly
putin will threaten this this is a very
important point uh if we get to the
point where nato is actually confronting
putin militarily and it looks like
things might not go well for him
putin will threaten nuclear war
okay
we've
first of all i want to say i am
again
i'm pretty confident although less
confident than i had been
uh that putin is not going to push the
button and launch global annihilation at
any point you don't think that he's
walked off his mind or will walk off his
mind sufficiently
uh to do any such a thing but he will
threaten it
um we've got to decide something up
front
we've got to decide that
um
we're willing to accept that risk and
that we're even willing to accept the
risk that putin will use a tactical
nuclear weapon
and that we will respond however we will
respond there's no need for us to
respond with nuclear weapons to that
kind of tactical nuclear weapons use and
we shouldn't
um but we need to accept the risk that
he will threaten that and the risk that
he will even do it
because if we decide that we're not
willing to run that risk then we might
as well surrender it all right now of
course of course because this he's going
to do this and we need this is something
else i'm going to say we've got we've
it's a terrible thing to say
but
this is the world that putin is creating
and i don't think that we can simply
surrender
uh to to that threat
all right uh friend fred you see those
questions yeah yeah
yeah we have actually i wish we had we
had our
wonderful um china scholars um
i think china was just just very
amateurishly on and i'm looking forward
to what you have to say
i think china will come will will not
comply with some and comply with others
uh for example i could give you uh if we
indeed are are hitting hard now
and we are um um banning of near stork
bank and zbirbank uh i believe the total
of about over 700 billion dollars on one
way or another uh with banning uh buying
their debt uh in other words uh their
their uh uh
whatever whatever uh
obligations they sell
uh i think in fact i remember if i
remember correctly in 2014 uh china
complied with with some of those
financial measures and the banks were
very uh i think almost stopped lending
um to uh russian companies or financing
russian endeavors i think one other
things there was just news about about
china buying a huge chunk of of russian
grain which apparently is also now as an
export is banned so i think china will
tread um uh very carefully and this
brings me to my favorite bet noir uh
which is which is the alliance between
russian china
china has so much more to lose
from from allying itself
with the vetoed banned sanctioned state
its embeddedness in world economy is so
much wider and sophisticated than
russia's which essentially short by the
way even now can sell its oil and gas
although we'll you know we'll see how
the how how um uh serious uh germans are
in in in shutting off temporarily um uh
nordos too
so so my sense is that they'll the
chinese will pick and choose
i'm not a china expert i the the only
thing i know is that the chinese since
2014
we have had an axis of opposing
sanctions among china iran and russia
and north korea that is very strong and
and those countries have all been
leading a charge to try to basically
make sanctions of any sort illegal
um and the chinese of course are worried
about sanctions against them
um as as parts of things that we might
do so i think the chinese are going to
be very resistant uh publicly as they
have been i mean they're going to
continue to reject publicly the
legitimacy of sanctions
um in terms of what they actually do i
agree with you i i don't think that she
is interested in losing a lot of bank
for putin
um on this uh war
and again i mean this goes back to the
way that putin has done this he's given
she no cover to defend him
this is so outrageously and overtly an
unprovoked act of of aggression that
putin is engaged in
that i think she is finding it is going
to find it hard
to provide putin the kind of cover that
he otherwise might be inclined to
um
so i i i think you're right but i i we
have people who know much more about
china than i do so i won't continue
on i'll take that i'll move to the last
question that yes which is
um
the question is can can we revisit the
statement that both the right and the
left of the u.s political spectrum do
not believe this matters to our nation
and that they will be against any
military action by u.s troops
um
look
we will see what coverage of this war
does to people
uh i have said i have been saying all
along that people
a lot of people were having trouble
imagining
how the world will change after putin
conducts an attack like this
and it is televised and everyone can see
what is going on
and we'll see if i'm right about that
um
i am noticing a steady coalescing
uh in many places on both sides of the
political spectrum here against what
putin is doing and once again
he has done so much to strip himself of
any sort of plausible cover for any
other for any of those who are other
than outright isolationists or who are
who are just prepared to repeat russian
propaganda lines of which i wish i had
said uh that gary kasparov quote
um they don't sound better in the
original russian
um
other than those than the then the
people who are going to be willing to
continue to do that i think that it's
we're going to see an erosion of
opposition
uh to u.s
resistance to the russian aggression
since the biden administration has taken
off the table fighting for ukraine that
isn't going to happen and we're not
going to have to have a political
argument about that i think that
probably would be divisive and i think a
lot of people would be opposed to it
um and but it's not on the table we're
not going to do that
as that becomes apparent and the
question becomes defending nato
i suspect we'll find that the proportion
of americans who are prepared to say
that we should not defend nato against
an unprovoked russian attack will be low
and especially as we watch the russian
continued destruction of of ukraine
[Music]
um and putin's fulminations and threats
i i hope that i'm right about this but i
don't think we're going to see a growing
of isolationist sentiment in this regard
i think we're going to see a swelling at
least in the short term
of support for defending uh nato and
america's allies and standing up to
uh
you know this this aggressor at this
time
so
i think we will we will not see a lot of
opposition
to military action by us troops to
defend nato countries
at least in the short term
um and the issue of defending you know
fighting to defend ukraine is not going
to be on the table
well what should we do
uh i think if there are no more
questions we uh we can we can wrap
let's see if there's any guidance
[Music]
okay okay
leon thank you so much um it's a
terrible day uh but uh i'm thrilled to
have had the opportunity to to learn
from you and discuss
uh discuss this from you and i look
forward to reading your book which uh is
incredibly timely and and
congratulations well thanks very much
fred probably a year from now but uh
delighted always to hear you and
actually this is this is the longest
uninterrupted uh
of caganisms that uh
that that i've had and
and i'm very grateful for this
opportunity
thanks very much and thanks for all of
you who watched
thank you very much have a great day